hello my name is Simon Clark and I am
both a youtuber and a climate scientist
I have a PhD in atmospheric physics from
the University of Exeter and I make
videos on a variety of topics in climate
physics now when you make videos like
that you tend to get some quite
interesting comments in the you know
discussion so I thought in this video I
could look through some of the recent
comments I've received and talk through
some of the points they're being raised
how many scientists drive less and fly
less name what they know secondly your
scientist dr. Adams said the influence
of the Sun on climate is not so much I
think he needs to be examined the data
for disclosure I'm no scientist well
thanks for making that very clear this
is in response to a video that I did
with dr. Adam levy climate Adam on
YouTube you should check him out and in
that we're talking about global cooling
and what they're asking is that the
sun's influence on the climate is
apparently not very much no what we were
saying in that video is that the sun's
influence on the climate changing is not
very much because the sun's output has
not changed significantly I already know
now what the comments section of this
video will be and it will be saying that
they we're entering into a global solar
minimum and that it's sunspot activity
and I can say with absolute confidence
that that is not the case that is not a
view that is held by scientists in any
high esteem as for how many scientists
derive and fly less as a result of
knowing what they know about climate
change a great deal of them a great many
scientists that I know for example don't
drive very much they will actually cycle
to work they will attempt to not fly as
much as possible I try and fly as little
as I possibly can I've been vegetarian
for nearly 10 years because I want to
try and live in my carbon impact in
short scientists do change their
behaviors as kind of practicing what
they preach
I guess climate changed is caused by
climate manipulation yes we've been
manipulating the climate causing it to
change because of carbon emissions you
might be new here very quick comment
here shut down climate and in shut down
climate that would be good
shut down China and India problem solved
I think this is quite a common
misconception that I see in my comments
that the developing world is the part of
the world which is responsible for most
of the emissions and we certainly hear a
lot of rhetoric around China in
particular however the fact is that 10%
of the world's population the richest
10% accounts for 50% of the world's
emissions and that's because our
lifestyles here in the developed West
very carbon intensive compared to the
lifestyles of people in for example
China and India but of course is a
snapshot at the moment that's not
something which is going to be
continuing to the
because both of those countries are
incredibly large they are also
developing socially and having expanding
middle classes and they are getting
still bigger there is a whole
complicated argument to be had about the
nature of industrialization in the
developing world and the fact that the
West was allowed to industrialize and
emit lots of carbon in doing so but now
we're saying to the developing world
that no you can't do that and that's a
complicated discussion to be had I just
like to say that there are technologies
available now that negate the need to
emit lots of carbon in particular when
looking at rural electrification in
places like Africa for example we
currently have technologies based on
renewables which will electrify most of
the people that have not yet received
electricity access for very little
carbon costs and for the record those
low carbon costs are anyway possible
because the investment of developing
nations China is basically the entire
reason that we can have a cheap reliable
photovoltaics so China is the reason
that the solar energy is looking as
cheap and as promising as it currently
does so whether or not we want to shut
down China in India I I wouldn't
recommend it
who is this guy Al Gore's brother I see
a lot of comments from this particular
user for the record know what happens a
global warming its climate change now
isn't it generally when a hypothesis
fails to accurately predict a phenomenon
it's because the hypothesis isn't good
now you're a really cool for questioning
when questioning is supposed to be the
backbone of science better not question
climate change lest you be guilty of
heresy well to answer those users
question global warming and climate
change are not the same thing global
warming refers to the global average
increase in temperatures that we see
when we add greenhouse gases to the
atmosphere climate change is if you like
the knock-on effect of trapping all that
extra energy in the system so that can
result in areas of being hotter than the
average warming but also colder than the
average warming as well as changes in
things like precipitation and
circulation patterns so they're not the
same thing as to whether a hypothesis
fails to accurate predictive phenomenon
it's not good it's just as well that
global warming's hypothesis that
radiative forcing due to anthropogenic
carbon increases the level average
temperature that's been borne out so I'm
yeah good job basic science by the way
these videos that I make on climate
tend to get swarmed by a lot of users
and BOTS in some cases who drop dislikes
on them for basically talking about
science so if you're enjoying this video
so far and finding an indication or then
do pop that like down there it does make
a pretty big difference someone here has
just posted the ideal gas law Wikipedia
what on earth you trying to say you
obviously don't understand full solar
forcing all the solar capital cycles
just trying to communicate there are
solar cycles and cycles in the Earth's
orbit around the Sun which have been
accounted for by climate scientists for
decades if only this user was around
then maybe we could have got it done a
little bit faster I'll draw the parent
they understand all them two millimeters
per year
Wow quick run for the hills this is in
reference to the global average change
in sea level actually it's a fair bit
more than that it's actually at the
moment I think more like 3.1 millimeters
per year that is the average and it's
getting faster and faster that's
actually what the whole video is about
perhaps if this commenter actually
watched it they might have used the
right figure in grasped that concept
that obviously doesn't sound terribly
scary however you have to remember that
a small change vertically and if you're
talking about just a couple of
centimeters of change over for example a
decade maybe by the end of the century
that's a lot of land laterally away from
the coastline which is going to be
flooded because you notice there's a lot
of this land is very gently sloping so a
small vertical change will result in a
large error of coastline loss that's not
actually the big issue here the big
issue is the fact that it raises the
average level of the sea which then
means that errors which are susceptible
to coastal flooding extend way further
inland when you get stuff like storms
storm surges happening then a lot far
larger areas are gonna be affected and
also areas which are densely populated
so much as it doesn't sound like very
much of a change per year first of all
it's getting faster and faster secondly
we're looking at the change over the
whole century which could be in worst
case scenario a couple of meters and
thirdly the areas that we're talking
about being affected are densely
populated and could have some really
catastrophic effects so run for the
hills
not actually the worst advice you could
give maybe in a couple of decades though
I want global warming the more the
better I want to plant coconut trees and
tropical for
in my garden taking this comment of face
value that's not really gonna be your
principal concerns yes changes in global
temperature and global climate will
result in different species of plants
animals migrating and being able to grow
different species where you previously
weren't able to do so however I think
people are far too flippant in many
cases about potential outcomes of
climate change obviously this stuff is
in the future we cannot say with
certainty any particular event will
happen but we think it is very likely
that we will see a huge amount of force
migration as a result of climate change
because of rising sea levels in places
like Bangladesh that would displace tens
of millions of people velocity migration
away from areas that become drought
prone that have had their resources
exhausted or because they can't grow
particular crops in a region anymore
another consequence would be the
clustering of extreme events because at
the moment when we get a particular
extreme weather event it's often a very
long time until the next extreme event
what's going to be a particularly big
problem in the future is when you get
one and then almost immediately another
you're already reeling from a disaster
such as an extensive drought or an
extensive hurricane or a heat wave as we
saw in Europe relatively recently how on
earth do you respond to that disaster
happening again in short order the fact
is it will put an overwhelming strain on
the response to these situations so when
we talk about climate change having
these impacts yes there is potentially
some benefits to be had if you want to
grow pineapples in your garden in the
middle attitudes but on the other end of
the spectrum we're dealing with some
pretty heavy consequences and I think
that should be borne in mind well I
think that's enough for one day
looking through comments I hope that you
enjoyed this journey that we went on
together I hope that it was educational
and maybe even a little entertaining
also by the way if you think that the
videos that I make on this subjects are
important if you think more people
should be seeing them and I should be
making more of them then consider
supporting me on patreon they'll be a
link down there in the description you
get access to videos a day early you get
some patreon exclusive behind-the-scenes
type of content and it makes a real
difference to how I can make videos so
if you think this is important please do
consider supporting if you did enjoy the
video please feel free to pop it alike
you can also subscribe to the channel if
you'd like to see more videos like the
ones these people have been commenting
on and if you'd like to see me do more
of this kind of thing then also let me
know down in the comments and I could
happily record some more videos like
this one thank you again for watching
and I'll see in the next one
you